new york is not proposing a shutdown of
the immigration system on the contrary
new york is planning on giving illegal
aliens
foreign nationals living in our country
in contravention of the law
a grant of 15 hundred dollars
i'm not joking this it sounds like a
babylon b headline but it's not
new york will offer quote one-time
payments of up to fifteen thousand six
hundred dollars
to undocumented immigrants who lost work
during the pandemic
according to reports that total fund is
going to come in at 2.1
billion dollars this as
americans are losing their businesses
losing their life savings losing their
livelihoods
depression suicidality up through the
roof among americans
we're going to give away five figures to
foreign nationals flouting our laws you
can't make it up
by the way this term it's being reported
as undocumented immigrants i was
watching putatively conservative cable
news
today and they used they were using the
word undocumented immigrants are
conservatives using this term now
an undocumented immigrant i was
undocumented
when i had a job when i was a teenager
because i was working off the books
that's not what that's not what we're
talking about we're talking about
foreign nationals
who are citizens of another country
living in our country and accessing our
services illegally
that is not just being undocumented it
it pains me to see conservatives
adopting this kind of language
it's not even so much about the money
it's the normalization of this thing
that we're gonna this is
national suicide we're gonna we're gonna
reward people
who break our laws we're gonna go real
nice and easy on blm and give them
whatever they want we're gonna pay
five figures to illegal aliens for
breaking our laws
and then we're going to imprison regular
americans in their own homes we're
not going to let them go out to work or
to see people or go to church
we're going to punish americans who
defend the american way of life
and we're going to reward people who try
to undermine the american way of life
because there is a major political
movement in this country
that has a purely negative purpose to
destroy our traditional standards in our
traditional way of life
which happens to be the subject of my
upcoming book speechless controlling
words controlling minds which you can
pre-order right now
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show to check out the
full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you